welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and sam remy spider-man established
our web slinging dope with charm action
and because it's sam raimi amazingly
can't be jump scares
that's a cute outfit did your husband
give it to you whoa
it's 2002. you may know or like later
takes on peter parker better but trust
me most of what you love about
spider-man has its dna
rooted in this film and i'm gonna break
down this full movie scene by scene for
all the hidden details and interesting
easter eggs that you might have missed i
definitely found some new stuff so let's
do this let's go back to the real
beginning the opening credits dissolve
into an
actual spiderweb creamy hid spiderwebs
and pest control jokes throughout this
movie
peter's bedroom wallpaper the sign
outside he and harry's apartment in new
york a terminix pest control sign in
times square
his whole world is a spider web and
there are a lot of things trying to
exterminate him mary jane watson makes
the school bus driver stop for peter
later when she gets a ride from friends
there's no one to stop the bus so peter
misses it
implying that mj has to do this for him
every day
his bully flash thompson is played by a
young joe manganello
and i say young despite all of these
actors in their 20s
playing teenagers that's just the way it
was done then how do you do fellow kids
and this
can't sit here nerdy girl was confirmed
to be liz
allen a classmate and love interest of
peter parker in the comics
on the field trip peter geeks out some
spiders
change colors to blend into their
environment
it's a defense mechanism harry rolls his
eyes out but then steals
spiders can change their color to blend
into their environment
really yeah it's a defense mechanism
actually it's interesting that colors
come up because the color palette is
central to this film peter
is often shown in red and blue meanwhile
the color green
represents a threat kind of like the
wicked witch of the west green is
everywhere
the floors and the vapor at oscorp their
graduation
the evil dish evil candles evil wall
paint lurking behind uncle ben before he
croaks peter bleeds through his
green shirt at thanksgiving while norman
wears peter's colors
the hero and the villain in a mutual
masquerade after their collision
but this early line about color
camouflage establishes a reason to all
this
see normally green is a natural
camouflage shade it's an earth tone
traditionally symbolizing goodness
heroism but
in a bustling urban jungle like new york
you're less likely to see green while
outside of central park then you are
colors like the flashing red and blue of
emergency lights
that is the natural camouflage peter
uses to blend into
his city's surroundings as an emergency
responder and there's a deeper
significance to the symbolism that we'll
get to at the end of this breakdown the
genetically modified spiders list
all of peter's superpowers that'll later
have arachnids from all three groups
possess very strange
intricate funnel-shaped web whose
strands have a tensile strength
proportionately equal to the type of
high-tension wire
which builds with nerve conduction
velocity so fast that some researchers
believe it almost borders on
precognition as spider-sense
yeah we got it but hey clever
foreshadowing there with the bridge
cable mentioned
setting up peter using his webbing to
suspend a bridge cable car
in the final act and the whole idea of
his webbing tensile strength being like
steel cables comes into the sound design
of the webbing which sounds like bending
metal when green goblin breaks through
later
one of these photos peter takes of mj
shows back up framed in spider-man 2.
see kids in 2002 being a bit of a
creeper was okay as long as she later
declares her love for you at her
friend's dad's funeral
at oscorp norman osborne the perfectly
cast willem dafoe butts heads with dr
mendel strom who in the comics is the
villain robot master
also gaunt we solved the horizon glide
and the multi-g balance issue
back to formula horizon glide multi g
balance issues those are the same glider
fixes peter disables in the later battle
but norman murders his chief glider
engineer sadly ironic since his eventual
death is caused by a glider oversight
whoopsie peter and norman gain their
power simultaneously peter from a red
and blue natural source
norman from a green unnatural one and
peter wakes up tuned
and strangely tan actually a few years
ago fans spotted how
raymie blurred the whole frame to show
peter's blurry lenses that he doesn't
need because he now has better vision
but later in spider-man 2
raymie fixed that so that only the
lenses themselves are out of focus when
this happens
at school peter catches mj a stunt that
toby maguire performed practically
though not after 156 takes as myth may
have you believe
it took toby several takes but that
number 156
came from bfx artist john dixtra joking
on the movie's commentary he said here
we go
take 156. they didn't do 150 takes they
just did a lot of them but people don't
understand jokes and bloggers need
clicks so here's how they did it the
slip and the throw were separate takes
but then in the close-up of toby he did
catch them from prop guys dropping them
just above frame
but if you look closely you can see
adhesive on the bottom of the apple to
keep it from rolling
and there are hidden magnets in the
jello and in the milk carton
so that they would land together still
not an easy stunt now famously unlike
peter parker's classic web shooter tech
sam raimi decided to make peter's
webbing in this movie
emit organically from his wrists and the
first time it accidentally squirts out
here he's inadvertently doing the hand
gesture
explaining why he has to do that gesture
later on the roof to trigger this
and then two men in their late 20s fight
in this high school
and peter back bends to see mj upside
down briefly a little foreshadowing of
their future kissy
watching this fight is peter's chess
club buddy played by prolific background
actor jesse hyman
whose many cameos went viral in 2011
he's great but our favorite extra is and
always will be bottom line beck tool
peter tries to activate the web
shazam referencing the catchphrases of
dc superheroes superman and billy batson
shazam it's a little weird how dc comics
exist
in this universe you're not superman you
know but hey it was the early days
before cinematic universes had borders
and the billboard that peter smacks into
is a car
making him a bug crush on the windshield
one of peter's suit designs is a black
suit with a full
chest red spider logo similar to his
symbiote black spider-man suit from the
80s comics with the white logo
which later became venom notes needs
more color another reminder that his
vibrant red and blue scheme is part of
his identity spider-man 3 be damned and
his final design includes visible note
off to the side
glove will fit over bodysuit showing how
he built his suit with a glove flap
and a nozzle connecting to his wrist
pores which years back fan spotted on
the rooftop garden scene peter
accidentally shatters his photo frame
with himself mae and ben
later you can see that he replaced this
frame and put the photo beside may's
hospital bed
norman reads a daily bugle article
reveals a bit of history if you look
closely married only once to the artist
caroline mulder he was divorced after 10
years of what was said to have been a
singularly strained and unhappy marriage
now actually in the comics norman's wife
is emily lyman also in norman's office
hangs a portrait of a woman who i assume
to be mrs osborne but
with this divorce and his later words
your mother was beautiful too they're
all beautiful
until they're snarling after your trust
fund like a pack of ravening wolves
maybe that's not a woman whose portrait
would hang up in his office i think it's
more likely this is norman's
mother and she wears a black dress and a
little later harry calls out
mj's cultural appropriation why didn't
you wear the black dress just
i wanted to impress my father he loves
black yeah he likes black dresses
because the woman in the picture wears
them and later mj does change her
wardrobe to try to impress norman by
wearing black
a great color for thanksgiving for my
dad's coming funeral
uncle ben drives a 1973 oldsmobile delta
88 honey beige
this is actually sam raimi's car he uses
it in pretty much all of his movies evil
dead dragged me to hell and although
it's not the same car it is similar to
the 1970 oldsmobile
coupe that stan lee drives an avengers
in game his final movie cameo
feel like that had to be at least a bit
intentional to uncle ben and then uncle
ben gets a generation of nerds the
closing line for their awful high school
valedictorian speeches
remember with great power comes great
responsibility
they actually resampled the late cliff
robertson's audio from this moment
in into the spider verse with great
power comes great responsibility but hey
before we continue
thanks to bang energy for sponsoring
this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has
zero calories yet it tastes so good
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from this flavor is pina colada
we're in those
warmer summer months now you might want
a fruity drink but you know not go
anywhere that serves fruity drinks i get
it that great tiki party can happen
in your mouth with a can of bang and it
gives you so
much energy so you can just do the limbo
by yourself
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order at bang dash
energy.com
when you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their keto coffee flavor their
sweet tea flavor
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25 percent
off at bangdashenergy.com using the code
newrockstars25
next macho man randy savage oh yeah
cameo says bones on mcgraw who according
to an easter egg in spider-man far from
home
also exists in the mcu octavius spencer
appears at the check-in desk and sam
raimi lead man bruce campbell cameos is
the announcer bruce comes back as the
theater usher in spider-man 2
and is a restaurant host in spider-man 3
which led to the great theory that
raymie was planning on revealing bruce
as an out-of-work performer quintin beck
mysterio spider-man 4
that never happened during the chase the
squad car has a license plate of 1927
could be an under the birth year of
spider-man artist steve ditko
or stan lee's comic illustrator
colleague john bashema now the nyc
montage shows a newspaper article with
redundant
text don't they know we actually read
these comedian jim norton cameos
he stinks and i don't like him and lucy
lawless cameos
guy with eight hands sounds hot but
deleted from this montage was a sequence
shown in an early teaser in which
spider-man foils a heist by webbing a
helicopter between
the world trade center towers but you
can actually see exactly
where that was removed from the other
side of the transition
zooming out from the towers reflected in
spider-man's mask eye
the towers also appear on the tv screen
in j jonah jameson's office
speaking of whom the perfectly cast jk
simmons does return as jameson in the
mcu and spider-man far from home and if
you think about it too hard it is
super fascinating that these universes
are connected like this and the next
episode of big question will explain how
this and that boson mcgraw crossover and
a whole bunch of other cool tie-ins
could all be leading to an existing
live-action spider-verse so check out
that episode james's editor robbie says
problem is we don't have a decent
picture eddie's been on it for weeks we
can barely get a glimpse of it
eddie a little not too rival bugle
photographer eddie brock
revealed as a tuper grace in the third
film mj works at the moon dance diner
which you rant heads know is the
workplace the composer jonathan larson
and actor jessie l martin and then you
friends heads might know as the former
workplace of monica geller
mj tells peter don't tell harry
and i won't tell harry no don't tell
harry i won't
a recurring problem for peter keeping
his best friend in the dark and driving
a wedge in their friendship
which becomes norman's final curse don't
tell harry
peter says i was late for work and dr
connors fired me
kurt connors shows up in the next film
of course in the comics he's the villain
the lizard and the primary foe of the
rebooted amazing spider-man
jameson reviews peter's photos they're
crap crap
crap mega crap i'll give you 200 bucks
for all of them journalistically
speaking all of peter's photos are
posed and too clean newspapers typically
run candid photos clearly capturing a
raw moment from a third-party observer
so yeah these are
crap but you know this is also jameson
he has no ethics he's just playing
hardball so you take the pictures i'll
make up the headlines okay all right
that okay with you
yes sir by verbally consenting to this
editorial arrangement peter legally
blocks himself from suing for libel
that's slander
it is not i resent that slander is
spoken
in print it's libel and as our friends
over at film theorists recently pointed
out
when peter steals that suit in the next
film he legally makes himself a criminal
technically proving jameson's libelous
headlines true
when norman gets fired defoe adds this
gross gesture of salivating wiping away
his goblin drool he kind of does this
later when mae slaps him at thanksgiving
when he is stung his inner ratted beast
comes out
stanley cameos during green goblin's
time square attack because who wouldn't
want to go see macy gray
in 2002 green goblin turns the oscorp
board into skeletons
also cameoing on his balcony is nicholas
hammond who played peter parker in the
70s series
and goblin greets mj hello my dear
we could see defoe's mouth under that
mask he's clearly saying something
different to me it kind of looks like
somebody stop me peter catches mj first
and then webs them both up to the
balcony rather than webbing her up from
the balcony to try to catch her like a
yo-yo because as we know from gwen stacy
that's how you snap a net norman gollums
with his goblin identity in the mirror
and defoe
makes this awesome smooth identity
transition from glee to horror
right as the camera revolves around him
as he sees the newspaper and then the
sassy daily bugle article describes
goblin as some kind of green freak from
another world
and calls out azcorp's unity festival
for celebrating the
nebulous theme of unity norman attacks
jameson to try to get spider-man's
photographer
i don't know who he is this stuff comes
in the mail you're lying some have
pointed out how jamison is covering for
peter here but really he's covering his
own ass because peter is the one
photographer who can supply
quality spider-man photos that is
bringing him business that's why he
doesn't give him up
also kind of creepy here how in this
scene goblins previously yellow
reflective eyepieces now have
irises painted in which makes him even
more haunting to his later victims
those eyes those horrible yellow eyes
and i love this the photo that the
beagle uses to report the attack is a
younger handsomer file photo of jameson
of course it is
peter saves mj they share their iconic
inverted kiosks
and mj says i better run tiger tiger is
mj's nickname for peter in the comics
and gets called back in the final words
of the next movie
go get him tiger after the burning
building attack the thanksgiving party
checks in on peter's room
bit of a slob isn't he all brilliant men
are on the floor is a beaver sweatshirt
for camp tamaqua
sam raimi's camp when he was a kid and
norman judging peter's messy room could
be a clue for him pointing to peter's
secret double life
something norman would understand
especially since his inner goblin is
always making a mess
the jungle out there had to beat an old
lady with a stick to get these cramps
just like norman's not so subtle work
was murder line
peter's also making a nod to how he had
you beat up goblin to get there when
goblin was disguised as an old lady in
that fire
and harry foreshadows his future right
if i'm lucky i'll become half of what he
is and later gets a father-son passing
the torch moment which leads to
this insane part
but this jump scare has yet another
reason to haunt your dreams because
years ago some fans spotted another
second goblin hiding behind him now it's
possibly foreshadowing harry following
his father
stepping out from his father's shadow to
take on the goblin mantle himself
but also five satellite dishes plus
goblin
is a sinister sin i'm just reaching
goblin takes mj to the brooklyn bridge
inspired by the eventful knight to quinn
stacy died comic which green goblin
dangled gwen over the bridge and then he
later died via his own glider as he does
in this movie
the cable slips out of peter's hand
leaving a streak of red
dye from his gloves and then new york
steps up
you missed this fight you mess with new
york you mess with one of us you mess
with all of us
and that first guy is actually actor
michael edward thomas who returns in the
next movie
we think there's a kid stuck on the
second floor goblin throws a grenade at
peter's face
the same move that peter will later use
on norman's son in spider-man 3
and peter gets the upper hand but
norman's final weapon is revealing his
identity
mr osborne i just love that shot
composition with the twisted
branch framing his eye don't look at me
but of course his confession is a trick
to stall peter while the glider gets
into position
but yeah it doesn't work oh
here or when spider-man homecoming does
this oh
really peter learns the value of
anonymity how symbols are more powerful
than any man
but with great power comes great you
know and the cost of this power
is human connection don't tell harry
norman dooms peter to a life of solitude
no harry
no mj even no one his enemies can target
and that power of symbols returns in the
final imagery of this film
as i said before the color palette is
key peter's red and blue scheme is this
city spider's natural camouflage in an
environment filled with flashing
emergency lights but let's be honest
stan lee steve ditko these guys designed
the character with flashy patriotic
colors to catch the eye and sell more
comics
in a film that had to adjust after
america's darkest moment
a movie that celebrates the people of
new york you cannot deny the symbolism
of seeing this hero framed with the
matching colors that draped the city of
new york in this time
a reminder that symbols can cloak us in
great power but
that is a precarious path that requires
thoughtful responsibility new rockstars
host weekly watch alongs of these
classic films on our discord server you
can join that by becoming a patron at
patreon.com new rockstars follow me on
instagram follow me rockstars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
you love and
godspeed spiderman
[Music]
you